und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka
guten Abend wer insgesamt 30 Stunden und
schlaflos durch die Nacht verhandelte
muss damit rechnen dass sich das
Publikum dann auch Zeit nimmt dass
Ergebnis unter die Lupe zu nehmen und
wie so oft liegt es im Auge des
Betrachters was man auf diesen 16
seitenpapier findet oder nicht der
Bundeskanzler jedenfalls nimmt das mit
der Lupe wörtlich und sieht alles sehr
sehr groß ein großes Werkstück hat er ja
schon im Vorfeld angekündigt das war
dann auch der Tenor als er sich heute im
Bundestag den Fragen der Abgeordneten
stellte Christian hübscher hat die
Debatte verfolgt
am Tag danach als alle Beteiligten
sichtbar um Lockerheit bemüht sind da
hat die Schlacht um die Deutungshoheit
längst begonnen was taugt dieses
Verhandlungsergebnis die Union geht den
Kanzler in der regierungsbefragung von
Tal an Herr Bundeskanzler ich frage
deshalb sie das Klimaschutzgesetz
aufweichen statt des einzuhalten wie
können Sie das verantworten jetzt kommt
das Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm das steht
in dem Text den sehr sorgfältig studiert
haben auch drin es wird Tempo geben
Beschleunigung und diese Aufgaben werden
alle zielgerichtet verfolgt der
Stillstand der letzten Jahrzehnte den
wir konservativer Politik zu verdanken
haben ist endgültig beendet jetzt kommt
Tempo in Deutschland die allgemeine
Lesart aber ist durchgesetzt hat sich in
diesen Verhandlungen nicht der selbst
ernannte klimakanzler sondern vor allem
die kleine FDP gerade beim Thema
Klimaschutz
beispielsektoriele bisher wurde die
Einhaltung der co2-vorgaben für die
Sektoren Energie Verkehr und Gebäude
getrennt betrachtet künftig soll nur
noch eine Gesamtrechnung geben schafft
dann zum Beispiel das fdp-geführte
Verkehrsministerium seine Einsparziele
erneut nicht muss die ganze Regierung
dafür gerade stehen Umweltverbände sind
entsetzt und jetzt haben wir ein Gesetz
das ist nur noch Stückwerk und dient
nicht mehr dazu wirklich auch einzelne
sektorenminister wie zum Beispiel den
Verkehrsminister dazu zu bringen ihre
Ziele auch zu erreichen dass der
Bundeskanzler das zugelassen hat es
wirklich ein Skandal und auch den Streit
um den schnelleren Ausbau von Autobahnen
entscheidet die FDP für sich 144
Teilstücke mit dringendem Bedarf können
nun schnell erneuert werden der
Verkehrsminister versucht nicht allzu
triumphpfahl aufzutreten mir ist das
völlig klar dass das für ein
Koalitionspartner ein großer Schritt ist
zu sagen wir bauen Autobahnen
beschleunigt aus verbreitern Fahrspuren
aber am Ende kommt es ja darauf an dass
wir die Infrastruktur vorausschauen zu
planen können dass sie den Bedürfnissen
der Menschen wirklich entsprechend um
die Autobahn wenigstens grün
anzustreiten beschließt die Koalition
Solaranlagen für den Straßenrand für die
Grünen kann das nur ein Trostpflaster
sein reicht es mit 1,5 Grad Fahrt
einzuhalten wo unsere Klimaziele
einzuhalten muss man ehrlich sagen nein
das sind wir noch nicht aber wenn ich
die Entscheidung habe wir gehen fünf
Schritte vor und drei zurück dann nehme
ich diese zwei Schritte
Wirtschaftsexperten hingegen loben das
lange verhandeln habe sich gelohnt die
Ampel habe frische Ideen wie man
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz zusammen
denkt zum einen ist es sinnvoll dass man
ein Lkw-Maut erhöht und damit die
Schiene finanziert man macht das LKW
fahren die Straße teurer und generiert
damit gleichzeitig Mittel um die Schiene
auszubauen das ist zielführend es sei in
diesen Verhandlungen oft zwei gegen eine
gegangen hört man heute aus der grünen
Partei nach außen aber versucht die
Ampel zu demonstrieren alles normal
zugeschaltet guten Abend guten Abend
Frau Slomka wenn man sich jetzt so die
Spielaufstellung am Tag danach ansieht
SPD und FDP super zufrieden und
glücklich und fröhlich und die Grünen
haben dann wieder ihren Anhänger jede
Menge zu erklären und zurechtfertigen
ist irgendwie doof für Sie oder naja wir
sind halt eine diskussionsfreundliche
Partei mit Anhängern die sehr neugierig
sind ich glaube die sind nicht nur
neugierig von denen sind im Moment
ziemlich viele ziemlich sauer
zumindestens wenn man so grüne
Organisationen von Bubi und DWF und so
weiter sich ansieht die Kommentare heute
diesen ziemlich vernichtend
also die sind jedenfalls nicht sauer auf
die Grünen sie sind sauer doch schon
darauf dass nicht mehr erreicht wurde
das liegt aber nicht daran dass die
Grünen nicht hart für mehr gekämpft
haben sondern dass wir am Ende
ja mit einer Ausgangslage konfrontiert
waren wo wir eine Lösung finden mussten
für die ganzen verhaken Probleme
und die ist gefunden worden es ist eine
Lösung wo natürlich auch Punkte drin
sind die jetzt nicht meinen Applaus
finden das wird die andere Seite wenn
ich so reden darf wenn man schon von
Seiten redet genauso sehen aber es sind
eben auch ein paar ganz gute Sachen
dabei Sachen die uns nach vorne bringen
die helfen und es sind auch bei denen
jetzt kritisierten Punkten
Formulierungen und Lösungen gefunden
worden die beispielsweise beim
Klimaschutzgesetz ein strenges
Klimaschutz weiter sichern aber wenn ich
jetzt statt ihnen heute Abend hier ein
bisschen sitzen hätte dann würde es mir
ehrlich gesagt schwer fallen ihn zu
fragen was sind die schlimmste Kröte war
die schlucken musste weil ich sehe
eigentlich keine
also
ich will jetzt die wie soll ich sagen
die gefundenen Ergebnisse nicht
vergleichen mit den ausgangsforderungen
aber die Formulierung zu den Autobahnen
beispielsweise sagt ja dass die Länder
in denen die Autobahnen sind das dazu
stimmen müssen das heißt also die Länder
entscheiden in Wahrheit darüber ob die
Autobahnen beschleunigt geplant oder
gebaut werden und das ist doch ein ganz
gutes Raster zu schauen ob diese
Abwägungsprozess der beschleunigt werden
soll sinnvoll ist oder nicht sinnvoll
ist das ist interessant aber mir geht es
nicht darum dass wir ein bisschen
schlucken müssen wirklich interessant
denn es ist ja auch in dem Papier davon
müssen jetzt einen großen
infrastrukturkonsens mit
konsultationsprozessen mit verschiedenen
Verbänden auch Umweltverbänden haben die
Länder müssen zustimmen das betonten sie
auch gerade mit anderen Worten der
beschleunigungsprozess in Sachen Verkehr
der wird jetzt dann quasi nacheinander
doch aufgehalten
nein nein das ist nicht ein aufhalten
sondern die Ländern müssen halt
zustimmen so haben wir uns geeinigt
damit
der die die Kenntnisse der Projekte dort
einfließen können und dann wird man
sehen wie viele von diesen Projekten
tatsächlich dann nach Wunsch der Länder
nach der neuen möglichen Regelung
beschleunigt geplant werden können aber
ich mir geht es gar nicht darum dass
hier irgendjemand Kröten schlucken muss
ich finde das eine falsche auf Rechnerei
die eigentliche Bedeutung von diesem
Koalitionsausschuss und deswegen hat er
ja auch so lange gedauert auch
ungewöhnlich lange und vielleicht auch
ärgerlich lange ist dass wir an sehr
vielen Stellen blockiert waren das viele
Gesetze die eigentlich entscheidungsreif
sind nicht entschieden werden konnten
weil alles irgendwie miteinander
verknüpft werden würde und das ist
aufgelöst worden oder hoffentlich
aufgelöst worden und ähm ich finde es
die falsche denkübung jetzt zu sagen wir
ziehen jetzt mal die Erbsen nach und sie
an da sind noch ein paar schlechten
schlechte im Töpfchen und da sind ein
paar gute im Kopf das ist alles gar
nicht gut das entscheiden ist dass diese
Regierung sich zu einer
Handlungsfähigkeit wieder vorgekämpft
hat und das ist doch das was unterm
Strich eigentlich zehn aber sie hat
diese Blockaden von denen sie sprechen
dann zum Teil jetzt dadurch gelöst dass
die Grünen nachgegeben haben also es
wird ihre Anhänger nicht versöhnen wenn
durch neue Autobahnabschnitte
verbrennermotoren mit 200 Sachen im
rattern und links und rechts stehenden
paar Solarpanel
erstmal glaube ich wenn man versteht was
da geschrieben wurde wenn man die Genese
kennt wenn man den Koalitionsvertrag
kennt dann relativiert sich vieles was
jetzt die an Vorwürfen oder als
unterstellten Vorwürfen in unsere Partei
reingespiegelt haben aber selbst wenn es
so wäre dass die Grünen nachgegeben
hätten was ich an vielen Stellen anders
bewerten würde selbst wenn es so wäre
das so schlimm ist es nicht viel mehr so
dass
irgendjemand ja mal einen halben Schritt
auf die anderen zu gehen müsste und es
ist nicht viel mehr so dass man
vielleicht sogar fast
stolz darauf sein kann dass wir die
Kraft haben eine Regierung wieder mit
zum Arbeiten zu bringen also ich weiß
gar nicht wo der Vorwurf sein soll dass
die Grünen auch von von von jungen
Menschen vor allem auch gewellt werden
weil sie sich erhoffen dass
Klimaschutzziele eingehalten werden und
da gab es ja jetzt doch nur einige
einiges an aufweichen ist total beglückt
darüber dass diese sektorenziele
aufgeweicht wurden er sich künftig nicht
mehr allein dafür rechtfertigen muss
wenn im Sekte im Verkehrssektor nicht
genügend getan wird das sind ja Dinge
die viele Menschen umtreiben die ihre
Partei wählen die freuen sich dann nicht
darüber dass man konnte erst einmal ist
für den Klimaschutz mit dieser Auflösung
natürlich eine Menge erreicht worden
denn die vielen Gesetze die jetzt aufs
Gleise gesetzt werden beginnen von dem
viel diskutierten Gebäude Energiegesetz
also der Energiewende im Wärme Sektor
über das Energieeffizienz gesetzt über
das bundesimmissionenschutzgesetz sind
ja große Pakete geschnürt wurden die
davor blockiert waren weil es keine
Lösung bei Straßen gehabt Beispiel
beispielsweise also das hilft erst
einmal dem Klimaschutz zu den Straßen
habe ich mich schon geäußert dann gibt
es ein großes Kapitel zum Umweltschutz
der quasi ähnliche Rechte bekommen soll
wie Infrastrukturausbau also die Umwelt
als Infrastruktur gesehen und wir haben
beispielsweise einen wirklich sehr
beachtliches bahnpaket geschnürt woraus
finanziert es sich aus einer CO2-Abgabe
auf die Lkw-Maut also es wird teurer auf
der Straße mit Benzinern also über den
CO2-Ausstoß Güter zu transportieren das
Geld geht ganz maßgeblich in die Schiene
die Schiene wird ausgebaut das wird
attraktiver das sind ja alles sehr sehr
gute Punkte keine Punkte für die man
sich entschuldigen muss und Punkte wenn
Sie so wollen die auf der Klimaschutz
Agenda stehen also noch einmal ob die
dann im Nachhinein auch wirklich dann
wirklich beschleunigt wird oder ob da
nicht dann diesmal in den Untiefen der
Realität dann doch das ein oder andere
aufgehalten wird also dann halten in
einigen Ländern werden dann Windräder
aufgehalten in anderen Ländern wollen
die Grünen keine Straßenprojekte dann
ärgert sich wieder Herr Wissing und da
wird all das worüber die letzten 30
Stunden diskutiert wurde quasi verlagert
neu diskutiert sehen sie die Gefahr
nicht ja die Gefahr besteht natürlich
das ist dann keine Gefahr die zwischen
uns notwendig einkehren muss aber
selbstverständlich findet sehr viel der
Umsetzung auf Länder oder kommunaler
Ebene statt das gilt für die für den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien wir
machen die Gesetze aber die Genehmigung
werden auf Landes- oder auf kommunaler
Ebene erteilt das gilt jetzt nach der
gefundenen Lösung auch für den
beschleunigten Ausbau dieser begrenzten
Liste für autobahnprojekte also der
Engpass Beseitigung das gilt im Teufel
auch für den Natur und Umweltschutz der
ebenfalls Ländersache ist da haben sie
natürlich recht ich hoffe dass ähm wie
soll ich sagen die der Anspruch an sich
selbst ich meine wir sind die Regierung
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland also der
der
Respekt vor dem was wir eigentlich
bewältigen müssen auch dazu beiträgt
dass wir unsere Ebenen so beraten oder
motivieren dass wir sagen okay jetzt
geht's nach vorne wir haben uns geeinigt
jetzt können wir auch an anderer Stelle
hoffen und erwarten und daraufhin
arbeiten dass Einigung ins Werk gesetzt
werden sagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister danke für das
Gespräch danke Ihnen
das Gespräch haben wir vorhin
aufgezeichnet was die Deutsche
Umwelthilfe von dem Koalitionskompromiss
hält dazu gibt es nachher im heute
journal Update ein Interview mit ihrer
Bundesgeschäftsführerin
ob es nun um den Einbau von Wärmepumpen
dass dämmen von Dächern oder den Ausbau
von Straßen geht es fehlt ja land auf
Land ab an Personal nicht nur im Bereich
bauen oder Technik sondern im Prinzip
überall es fehlen Menschen die Senioren
und Kranke pflegen es fehlen Menschen
die an Flughäfen Koffer auf Gepäckbänder
hießen es fehlen Mitarbeiter in Behörden
und Auszubildende in Steuerkanzleien die
Bundesregierung will dem nun mit einer
Art Doppelstrategie entgegenwirken
einerseits mehr Jugendliche in
Ausbildungen holen und die Einwanderung
von Fachkräften Fachkräften erleichtern
einen entsprechender Gesetzentwurf wurde
heute im Kabinett eingebracht mir dazu
von Klaus Brodbeck
wie ihr geht es vielen 25 Jahre junge
Mutter von Madagaskar nach Erfurt doch
ihre Berufsausbildung hier cantia
mangels Kinderbetreuung 9 Teilzeit
machen Deutschland macht es nicht leicht
doch Tier bleibt dran wenn meine
Ausbildung fertig ist dann bekomme ich
so eine und befristete Vertrag und dann
ja kann ich lange bleiben es soll
leichter gehen schneller mit weniger
Bürokratie und mehr Anreizen sich für
Deutschland zu entscheiden mit unserem
neuen Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
werden wir mehr
zu wollen in den deutschen
Arbeit möglich
macht notwendig wenn wir jetzt nicht
alle Register ziehen wir werden alle
Register ziehen dann droht Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel zu einer dauerhaften
Wachstumsbremse für Deutschland zu
werden drei Punkte prägen das neue
Einwanderungsrecht als Qualifikation
reicht künftig ein anerkannte Abschluss
um in allen Branchen arbeiten zu können
mit ausreichender Berufserfahrung soll
Arbeit noch ohne Abschluss möglich sein
und Bewerber mit Potenzial sollen ihre
Chance per Punktesystem bekommen geht
nicht sagt die Union und klagt über
Personalmangel als hätte sie nie regiert
wenn niemand die Formulare bearbeitet
weil es sich die
Antragsformulare zu Tausenden stapeln
dann nützt die ganze punkteverteiler
reinigt sondern dann braucht es nicht
mehr Punkte sondern mehr Personal um das
zu bearbeiten
2013 blieb eine offene Stelle
durchschnittlich 2,6 Monate unbesitzt im
vergangenen Jahr dann schon 4,6 Monate
statt sechs Arbeitslosen pro offener
Stelle waren es 2022 nur noch 1,8
höchste Zeit zu handeln jetzt sagt man
auch Leute die vielleicht
Berufserfahrung haben aber keinen
Abschluss können ins Land und sogar
Leute die eine Stelle suchen das ist
wird also deutlich wirksamer sein zur
Fachkräfte an Werbung als das was er
vorher hatten es geht also gar nicht so
sehr um fertige Fachkräfte sondern darum
dass wir als Gesellschaft und uns öffnen
um für junge Menschen auch ohne
Ausbildung und Qualifizierung zu diesem
Zeitpunkt zumindest attraktiv
werden in seltener Einigkeit forderten
arbeitgeber-präsident und dgb-chefin
bereits gestern Zuwanderung von
Fachkräften besser zu organisieren wir
brauchen schnellere Visa-Vergabe
beschleunigte Berufsanerkennung aber
eben auch statt
Ausländerbehörde kommunale
einwanderungsbüros die die Menschen als
Ganzes sehen auch deutschen
Arbeitskräften soll geholfen werden eine
Ausbildungsoffensive soll folgen vieles
dürfte leichter werden nicht nur für Sie
und welche Löhne hierzulande bezahlt
werden den Fachkräften die man sucht
darüber wird derzeit ja heftig
gestritten und damit geht es jetzt bei
dir weiterhelms bei den
Tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
Dienst geht die aktuell dritte
Verhandlungsrunde möglicherweise noch
heute Abend in die entscheidende Phase
verschiedene ist es am Ende möglich von
Einigung über Vertagung oder Schlichtung
bis Streit seit Montag beraten die
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgeber über eine
Tarifvereinbarung für die rund
zweieinhalb Millionen Beschäftigten von
Bund und Kommunen und diese
Gesprächsrunde war bis zum heutigen
Mittwoch angesetzt
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius tauscht
die Spitze des beschaffungsamtes der
Bundeswehr aus die bisherige Präsidentin
wurde von ihren Aufgaben entbunden es
übernimmt die derzeitige Vizepräsidentin
Annette
ziel sei es schneller und effektiver zu
werden seit Jahren gibt es Kritik an
langen Entscheidungswegen
der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossy hat heute das
ukrainische Atomkraftwerk saporisia
besucht das seit rund einem Jahr von
Russland besetzt ist grossi zeigte sich
wegen zunehmender militärische
Aktivitäten um das Gebiet besorgt er
wirbt für ein Sicherheitskonzept damit
es nicht durch Gefechte zu einem
Atomunfall kommt seine Behörde hat seit
September 2022 ein ständiges
Expertenteam in dem Kraftwerk
das Gesetz zur Bekämpfung von Kinderehen
ist in seiner jetzigen Form nicht
verfassungsgemäß und muss nachgebessert
werden nach einer Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts bleibt es zwar
dabei dass im Ausland geschlossene
Kinderehen in Deutschland unwirksam sind
bemängelt wird aber dass die Folgen
daraus nicht geregelt sind etwa die
Unterhaltsansprüche übergangsweise gilt
hier jetzt der Unterhaltsanspruch wie
nach einer Scheidung
israels Ministerpräsident Netanjahu hat
Kritik von US-Präsident beiden an der
geplanten Justizreform scharf
zurückgewiesen beiden hatte ihn
aufgefordert die Justizreform aufzugeben
netanjah sagte Israel treffe seine
eigenen Entscheidungen nicht aufgrund
von Druck aus dem Ausland nach
Massenprotesten stoppte er vorerst die
umstrittene Gesetzgebung diese sieht
unter anderem den Ausbau der
Machtposition der Regierung vor
zugegeben Bellevue ist nicht Versaille
dessen grandiosen Spiegel sein haben wir
in Berlin nicht zu bieten dafür aber
weniger revolutionären Krawall bei
Streiks deshalb hatte König Charles
seine Reise nach Paris ja abgesagt und
so wird nun in den Geschichtsbüchern
stehen das Deutschland das erste
auslandsreiseziel des neuen Königs war
dass das überhaupt ein europäisches Land
ist und nicht ein Staat des Commonwealth
ist sowieso bemerkenswert es liegt ja
große Symbolik in den Reisen der Royals
ihre majestätten sind dabei meist im
Auftrag der Regierung unterwegs als
wandelnde Stimmungsaufheller und da
scheint nach dem brexit Europa gerade
die Region die mehr Zuwendung bedarf
Mini hat den Besuch beobachtet
es gibt ein strenges Protokoll für jede
dieser Vorfahrten für jedes
Händeschütteln für jedes Foto und doch
wirkt dieser Besuch gar nicht so steif
wie man denken könnte wenn ein neuer
König eine neue Königs Gemahlin nach
Deutschland kommen fest beim Kette im
Schloss Bellevue 130 Gäste und ein gut
gelaunter König Charles der dritte
es ist schön von Ihnen dass
Sie gekommen sind und mich nicht mit
einem Dinner for one
alleine lassen
Angela Merkel das halbe Kabinett tote
hosensänger Campino eine illustro Runde
laut dem König und der weiß an wen hier
sowieso auch alle denken
Freundschaft zwischen unseren beiden
Ländern das Band zwischen uns bei meiner
Mutter die Queen immer sehr wichtig
ich möchte mich noch einmal bei ihnen
allen bedanken für die liebevollen
Nachrichten die wir aus Deutschland
bekommen haben nach ihrem traurigen Tod
im vergangenen Jahr
politisch allerdings hat es geholper
zwischen Europa und Großbritannien in
den vergangenen Jahren das König Charles
erste Reise nach Deutschland geht ist
ein bisschen Zufall eigentlich sollte es
ja zuerst Frankreich werden und doch
aber ist das auch ein Zeichen dass die
Briten drei Jahre nach dem brexit setzen
wollen und Berlin hat sich aufgerüscht
so gut ist das kann
[Musik]
und so absolviert der 74-Jährige Charles
als König eine Premiere im Ausland zum
ersten Mal die militärischen Ehren sanft
dirigiert vom Bundespräsidenten halbe
Drehung bitte auch politisch bitte fast
sechs Jahre auf den Tag genau als das
loslösendes Vereinigten Königreichs von
Europa begann
wir schauen unter veränderten
Bedingungen und doch gemeinsam nach
vorne was auch immer vor uns liegt ich
weiß unsere deutsch-britische
Freundschaft bleibt wichtig sie bleibt
stark aber frenchel ist important
und von den unzähligen Gastgeschenken
die ein König so erhält hat der
Bundespräsident eines in dem sich
Charles begegnet als 13-Jähriger bei
seinem ersten Deutschland besucht 1962
an der Seite seines Vaters Prinz Philip
eine Zeitreise für den König der auf die
Zukunft anstößt eine die nachhaltig sein
soll morgen dazu mehr bei seiner Rede im
Bundestag
und jetzt geht's bei dir weiter weniger
glamourös mit aktuellen
Wirtschaftszahlen ja die öffentlichen
Schulden sind Ende 2022 auf einen neuen
Höchststand gestiegen das meldet der
Statistische Bundesamt nach vorläufigen
Berechnungen zum Gesamthaushalt von Bund
Ländern Gemeinden und Sozialversicherung
bei real,- welche Folgen hat so ein
Schuldenberg also Deutschland kann es
sich noch leisten aber so ein
Schuldenberg ist lang LEBIG und eine
Belastung für jüngere Generationen
außerdem ist es in den vergangenen
Monaten deutlich teurer geworden
Schulden zu machen weil die Zinsen
gestiegen sind viel schneller als
Notenbanker und Politiker je gedacht
haben ja und das Geld für den
Schuldendienst das fehlt nun für andere
Ausgaben und Investitionen die schweren
Krisen corona-hilfen Kosten für die
Energiewende Gas und Strompreis Bremse
haben tiefe Spuren in den Bundesfinanzen
hinterlassen der deutsche Staat steht
nun mit einem Rekordbetrag in der Kreide
Ende 2022 lagen die Schulden bei rund
2.367 Milliarden Euro 2% mehr als ein
Jahr zuvor macht pro Kopf eine
Verschuldung von mehr als
28.000 Euro dabei legten die Schulden
des Bundes und der Kommunen unterm
Strich zu die der Länder hingegen
ausgenommen Sachsen-Anhalt verringerten
sich ein Blick noch auf den DAX der
konnte heute wieder ordentlich zulegen
um mehr als ein Prozent was auch an
einer Äußerung eines ezb-direktors liegt
der meinte die Notenbank rechnen mit
einem raschen Rückgang der Inflation zum
Ende des Jahres ganz neue Töne die
Hoffnung auf eine künftig weniger
aggressive Zinspolitik machen und das
wäre dann auch eine Erleichterung für
die Bundesregierung
vielen Dank
die Energieminister der Länder dringend
auf einen beschleunigten Aufbau der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft in Deutschland mit
der erreicht werden kann ist eines der
Themen auf der zweitägigen Konferenz der
das so Chefs in Merseburg in
Sachsen-Anhalt auch über die Einführung
eines günstigeren Strompreises für
industriebe soll diskutiert werden die
deutsche Wirtschaft klagt bereits seit
längerem über Energiekosten die im
internationalen Vergleich sehr hoch sein
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr zwei 19 37 40 43 48 Superzahl 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
flotte.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
das Thema Zuwanderung hatten wir ja in
der Sendung schon im Zusammenhang mit
dem Fachkräftemangel wenn von Migration
die Rede ist wird das ja meistens einem
bestimmten aktuellen Zusammenhang
gesehen er wünschte oder unerwünschte
Zuwanderung und immer nehmen wir uns als
aufnehmendes Land war abgesehen davon
dass es ja auch heutzutage deutsche
Auswanderer gibt war Migration über die
Jahrhunderte oder gar Jahrtausende aber
natürlich immer ein Phänomen in alle
Richtungen ins große Einwanderungsland
USA etwa kamen im 19 Jahrhundert
Millionen Armutsflüchtlinge aus Europa
viele aus Deutschland in New York
dominierten sie ein ganzes Stadtviertel
little Germany
solution und aktuellen Völkerwanderungen
widmet sich derzeit eine
kulturausstellung in Nürnberg Barbara
luke hat sie sich angesehen
was nehmen wir mit wenn wir aufbrechen
was lassen wir zurück
wohin gehen wir und was wird uns dort
erwarten
ohne Migration gibt es keine menschliche
Kultur das ist etwas was ich schon immer
abbildet schon bevor Menschen sesshaft
wurden da war das unterwegs sein die
Normalität
unterwegs sein schwebend wie Zugvögel
Migration ist Bewegung so jedenfalls
sinniert IVA über ihr Lebensgefühl als
Migrantin
[Musik]
es gibt so ein Begriff Zug Unruhe und
das spüre ich auch ich habe
vielfach in meinem Alltag das Verlangen
woanders hinzu wollen ich habe wie so
Hummeln im Arsch
die Ausstellung erzählt von Wanderungen
und fluchten durch die Jahrhunderte
davon wie sie Identitäten prägen
Sehnsüchte schüren bereichernd sind oder
Leid hervorrufen
junge Künstlerinnen die aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen nach
Deutschland migrierten spiegeln in der
Ausstellung ihre Erfahrungen für Adrien
beispielsweise sind Haare Sinnbild für
Migration
[Musik]
wir sind doch alle Reisende wir kommen
doch alle von irgendwoher Migration
bedeutet wer sind wir alle Fragen woher
kommst du aber im Grunde sind wir doch
alle nicht speziell von hier
vielleicht ähneln sich die Bilder
deshalb so sehr die heilige Familie
flieht aus Bethlehem in Tücher gehüllt
Jahrhunderte später die gleiche Szene
dreht sich die Welt im Kreis
Migration für ein besseres Leben
Migration aus Wagemut aber vor allem aus
Angst vor Krieg und Gewalt für Simona
die aus Russland Flo bleibt das Ankommen
ein lebenslanger Prozess
[Musik]
ich bin nicht das und ich bin auch nicht
das und ich bin nichts davon und
gleichzeitig alles es ist einfach
wahrscheinlich wie so ein lebenslange
Verletzung mit der man dann umgehen
lernt und die vielleicht auch mich dann
besonders macht
und so wandert die Menschheit weiter
freiwillig oder zwangsweise und
vielleicht zu spekulieren die
Ausstellungsmacher am Ende wird der Weg
hierher auf den Mond dann unsere größte
Wanderschaft
ja und wahrscheinlich schafft die
Menschheit ist dort dann auch nicht eine
bessere Welt zu errichten einer der
Staaten der seine Bevölkerung schon seit
langem in die Flucht treibt ist Iran
gleich im auslandsjournal gibt es einen
Bericht von Jörg Brase die Miss gelungen
ist mit einer iranischen Schülerin zu
sprechen die Opfer eines der mysteriösen
Giftanschläge wurde und um 0 Uhr 30 gibt
es dann unser heute schon Update mit
Christopher Wehrmann und wir melden uns
morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das ist ein richtig großes
tief dass ich hier bei Island dreht und
das wird einen kleinen Ableger erzeugen
morgen bildet er sich hier über dem
Atlantik das ist das Sturmtief Markus
und das wird bis Freitag Abend bereits
die Nordsee erreicht haben heute Nacht
fällt erstmal Regen zunächst im Osten
dann aber auch im Westen und da können
schon am frühen Morgen die ersten
Gewitter dabei sein der Wind kommt aus
südlichen Richtung und so wird das noch
mal eine milde Nacht die Temperaturen
sinken am Oberrhein bis 13 Grad bis vier
Grad in der Oberpfalz und morgen gibt's
dann kräftige Regenschauer und Gewitter
zwischendurch zeigt sich aber auch mal
die Sonne länger regnet es am Alpen Rand
und auch in Schleswig-Holstein und schon
morgen ist der Wind recht kräftig
besonders über den Mittelgebirgen
reicht's für leicht mal für stürmische
Böden und so wird das auch morgen noch
mal ein milder Tag mit
Höchsttemperaturen von 12 Grad an der
Nordsee und 18 Grad am Oberrhein noch
wärmer als bei uns ist es naturgemäß in
Frankreich oder auch in Südspanien da
steigen die Temperaturen in Spanien
morgen bis 30 Grad und wenn sie jetzt so
denken wie sieht's denn in der Karwoche
aus nächste Woche da ist dann ja auch
später dann Ostern leider wird dieses
Tief hier Richtung östliches Mittelmeer
ziehen deswegen ist von einer Erwärmung
bei uns nichts zu erwarten denn wir
kommen auf die kalte Nordostseite das
bedeutet erstmal Strom am Freitag in der
Mitte und im Süden am Samstag dreht der
Wind an der Ostsee bereits auf Nordost
und am Sonntag liegen die Temperaturen
dann nur noch bei 5 bis 11 Grad guten
Abend